i read an article recently in instyle
magazine that made
a light bulb go off yes i had
an aha moment they put out an article
about the idea of a divorce registry
where friends and family can come
together to help an individual replace
items around the house that they lost in
a divorce it's to celebrate a fresh
start the way we celebrate new
beginnings like a wedding
and i'm just so excited to talk about
this today with an
incredible mom of two please welcome
laurie simonelli hi
hi lori hi how are you well i'm really
good
because a light bulb went off and then
our amazing producers found you
and you got divorced this year and
i just want to ask you how is it going
how was it for you
how is your new normal in the times of
so many new normals look it wasn't easy
i'm great right now but you know we were
married
almost 17 years we were together 20. so
when something like this happens it's
you kind of lose your identity
um but my ex's name is nick
and we we pulled out all the stops you
know we tried
everything to not have a divorce we
didn't want to do that we both believed
in marriage
we tried everything together as a couple
we realized
we can't put those pieces back together
and so we
you know we finally came to the
realization that we needed to kind of
end this chapter
well it's funny that you use that word
chapter
because life is this unwritten book
and i've had to convince myself of these
things when i was like 13 and washed up
and
just a wasteoid and i was like i felt
like that chapter would be my narrative
forever
but you realize that the book keeps
getting written and you're actually the
writer
and this is a chapter right maybe the
closing of one
the opening of the next um i appreciate
that you use that word
i think it symbolizes a lot of things um
what has been a difficult aspect about
this that you
didn't foresee you know i think probably
one of the hardest things i saw was the
first email that came through
that said siminelli verse simonelli and
i said what is this
like we're nick and laurie we're not
simonelli versus simonelli so that was
very difficult to process and then you
had the moments where you
you are speaking through attorneys and
it's just very impersonal but
nick and i always tried to kind of like
bring it back down and
we we talked throughout everything we
lived in the same house throughout the
whole divorce we ate dinner with our
kids
um so you know that was hard
with attorneys and one of the hardest
things was sitting down with the kids
yeah um and this article said when
someone gets divorced
often their friends and social circles
want to show up
but they are not quite sure how and
a registry gave something concrete to
point to
and that was where the light bulb went
off for me i thought
why is there not a registry because
inevitably in
i would say the majority of divorces
things are divvied up sometimes people
have
catastrophic losses um but what did your
friends do for you
you know i have a few very very close
friends
and they were just there they were there
to listen
um they just made me laugh yeah um
you know look they knew that we had that
nick and i had a great relationship so
there was never any bad feelings i mean
they're still friendly with nick
right well i think that you and nick
have a very rare american
in this circumstance we do we're lucky
please do a ted talk lori
i think it'll get a lot of hits
and your friends julie melissa and
hillary
they've been watching this whole time
and they're here hi ladies
hi oh my god
there they are
and we talked all about you and
um we have a little surprise for you
please watch this
hi hi thank you guys so much it's really
really nice to meet you
thank you for doing this for lori she is
the most amazing person and she
would give the shirt off her back to any
of her friends
i think there's only one silver lining
of any breakup and it's girlfriends
i'm there for her whenever she needs me
to talk or laugh
i just love her to death she's such a
good person so every day on my way to
work i would call her for like a half an
hour chat on the way in and
you know most days she would start off
crying and at the end we were both
laughing just because you know to remind
her like her life's not over it's you
know a new beginning and
think of it that way i know when lori
had gotten divorced
she was shocked when you're getting
divorced you're like i'm fine
everything's cool but maybe it's not
yeah why are we allowed to have a
registry
for weddings i thought a divorce
registry
yes it's amazing why hasn't anybody done
this so far
i know when i went through a divorce we
just kind of went through the house like
okay you take this
i'll take this you take this all so i
know she's missing a lot of stuff
you know especially in her kitchen when
i think of registries
i immediately go to kitchen stuff is
there anything else she's missing or
lacking like
bedding or pillows or soft items
lori is definitely like farmhouse kind
of style yeah
that's right totally lori's you know
kind of taste he loves peanut m
ms in like the prettiest bowl she's a
new girl yeah
i know like something that she
absolutely has been saying like a
million times that she needs
is you know a console yeah say
i i like both of these and they're
incredibly affordable
um i believe lori wanted to be able to
kind of diy herself
i thought this vacuum was super smart
that will honestly be
probably laurie's favorite thing perfect
i think i think we get through it with
our friends so
thank you guys so much for doing this
with me and letting me come into
your circle let's do this
[Music]
i just loved meeting your friends hi
ladies
what do you think lori what are you
thinking feeling
they're amazing um i mean hillary i've
known
forever i've known her since high school
and uh she's amazing um
and julie she's like
the most unbelievable person
and uh melissa melissa is me times ten
we always laugh about it my kids call
her crazy melissa she comes in my house
and we laugh from the moment
she comes in until the moment she leaves
and my kids
never come out of the rooms but when
they hear her they're like melissa's
here and they run out
this was so great to do this with you
guys and
we created this registry and we
purchased every single item
on it so let's
this is all for you lori and
melissa julie hillary and i just
thought thoughtfully about a few little
goodies who might get you going
and yeah exactly oh my god
well i have to tell you i don't think i
would have had this idea if i wasn't
working on this company i just created
um with my partner shae hung
called beautiful which is all kitchen
stuff
i i i'm flabbergasted and i
can't believe these three are here it's
like overwhelming
well there is no clock that measures
when
things shift evolve it's a mysterious
clock that just takes time but our
girlfriends get us through it
so thank you julie melissa and hillary
and lori